this is a production of cornell
university
okay thank you again for the
introduction and also
thank you for the invitation to present
our results here today um like gillian
mentioned
it's close to one o'clock in the morning
here so apologies if
um i'm not mentally spry tonight
um so like gigan mentioned in the
introduction
we had the chewy lab are interested in
[Music]
biosynthesis of secondary metabolites of
filamentous fungi
and i came here with a bit of background
and
of interest in metabolic engineering
um and i figured i would do it on
um ribosomal peptides because uh
they're much simpler in their by
synthetic logic
than these mega enzymes that gillian
already mentioned
however these
ribosomal peptides are also sort of the
unloved uh stepchildren of the of the uh
natural product family and fungi so
they're vastly unexplored
so the engineering part was harder than
i thought
at the same time also got into this
project which is
elucidation of biosynthesis of a
secondary metabolic peptide and that was
really fruitful
so today i'm going to share with you
these results
of the collaboration of our lab gains
lab and
um peter solomon's lab at anu um
yeah so um as gaia mentioned it's about
victorian
um the peptide produced by cochlear
um on necrotrophic fungus um
and i'm going to go into uh the
backstory a little bit
galena's already done a good job of
introducing it
um so
oops okay um
so in the 1940s in the united states um
oat farmers had
um a problem with another disease called
crown rust of oats caused by the
biotrophic pathogen
p coronado and to combat
that disease then they introduced
an old cultivar that was resistant to
chronic oats
from argentina and this cultivar is
called
victoria or what's called a victoria oat
and that worked nicely it's resistant to
crown rust
and so it was widely adapted and widely
planted in the united states however
within
a couple of years a new disease emerged
that
selectively selectively infected those
victoria oats and that disease is
victorious bladder votes
caused by cochlear victory and
what's really interesting about this
disease is that
the resistance to crown rust is directly
linked to the susceptibility to victoria
applied
of oats so that was in the 1940s
um as soon as this
disease emerged and it reached epidemic
proportions in the united states
victoria um cultural of oats was
quickly abandoned so that was pretty
much the end of the
problems with this disease so
why is it still of relevance today and
why has it been
um looked into for decades it's because
of this interesting link between
susceptibility
and resistance
so this overlap between these
between these two pathogens there
um and and the key to this overlap
or the key to at least the
disease caused by victoria is the
peptide
victorian um so
uh from a scientific perspective um
there's a lot of uh good research done
over the years there's
two landmark papers i want to point out
in 1947
me and murphy when the disease first
emerged they studied it
and what they found was that when they
cultivated cochlear victory
in liquid culture and sort of filtered
the
culture liquid and
sterilized it so that there was no
living fungus left in the culture
filtered
and then applied it to susceptible alt
then they observed that these the simple
old
developed the same disease symptoms as
if it was
infected with the fungus itself so that
was
the first time it was demonstrated that
um
a necrotic or a fungus could secrete
a toxin that by itself could cause
disease symptoms identical
to infection by the same fungus
so that was in 1947 another
landmark paper was the 2007 paper
from thomas walbert and jennifer lauren
and co-workers
where they elucidated
how exactly that compound victorine
achieved this toxicity
and what it comes down to basically is
that victorian
sort of mimics a biotrophic effector
and induces um
a hypersensitive response in the host
plant so
induces cell death and then takes
advantage of that cell death
to colonize the host so
how does that work in more detail so
that's from thomas walbert's work
what they did was study uh
this interaction in in arabidopsis and
at the center of this
of of this interaction is a thyroidoxin
called trxh5
and this thyrodoxin is central to
regulating plant immune responses so
that makes the target
for um biotrophic effectors
so when a biotrophic effector binds
and inhibits jxh5
and plant immune responses that
in the old um zigzag model of
host pathogen interaction leads to
what's called effect that triggered
susceptibility
and then in the evolutionary
evolutionary arms race between
host and pathogen then some hosts
develop resistance to that
by employing um a guard protein
and that guard protein monitors
the tier xh5 and
if it detects binding of the biotrophic
effector
and suppression of the txh5 it induces
the hypersensitive response or the cell
death
which halts an infection by a biotroph
so it's localized cell death and then
the the affection by the biotroph
stops at that point however what
victorian then does
is mimic that biotrophic effector
so by having the same
inhibitory activity on txh5
as that biotrophic effect that's been
defeated by the plant already
it sort of wants to be called by
the god protein which is lv1 in
arabidopsis
that then induces cell death but
because cochlea cochlear victoria is a
necrotrophic
fungus it actually profits off cell
death
and that leads to colonization and
what's interesting is that
victorian has the same inhibitory
effects on th5
but without the god protein that
inhibition of the plant immune response
um is still not enough for cochlear to
actually colonize the plant
so that's why it's called the whole
selective toxin as
you mentioned earlier um it's
selectively
only um is successful in infecting
plants that have that
gut protein and that resistance to um
that biotroph and that also explains
how disease susceptibility
um to calculus victoria and disease
resistance
to p coronado are linked
so um that's an interesting mechanism
um but what actually
is victorian so victoria is a set of
small psychic peptides
if you look at it so this is victorian c
that i
have here on the slide victorian c is
the
major constituent but it's a mixture of
six
similar compounds directly motor
victorian c
and if you look at the structure um it's
kind of difficult to figure out what it
actually is um
it's not a true cyclic peptide it's not
cyclized head to tail it doesn't have
only peptide bonds it's not a depth c
peptide
it doesn't have an ester bond and the
unusual amino acids
suggest and non-ribosomal origin
so gilligan's lab did a lot of work on
this
previously and they sequenced
the cochlear victory genome
in 2011 and they knocked out all the
nrps gene clusters in cochlear is
victoria
but found that the mutants would still
produce victorian
so um the big reveal here and i guess
it's
not a big reveal anymore at this point
because it's been published
is that victorian is what's called a rip
so what is a rip
stands for ribosomally synthesized and
post insulation modified peptide
and ribs have been known in bacteria and
plants for quite some
time but their discovery
in filamentous fungi is fairly recent
only over maybe a decade or more
and although very few of them have
actually been
characterized um
an abundance of hypothetical
rip gene clusters have been found in the
genomes of filamentous fungi
and their biosynthetic logic as i
mentioned earlier is
it's quite simple so um
the rib is encoded directly in the
genome in
uh what's called a precursor peptide or
as it's
named here pro protein so
the precursor peptide contains
one or in filamentous fungi
multiple copies of the core peptide and
the core peptide
is the amino acid sequence that makes up
the backbone of the mature product so
during rib biosynthesis these core
peptides
are cleaved out of the precursor peptide
and then endowed with post insulation
modifications
um not necessarily in that order and the
final product
usually um is cyclized so in all
categorized fungal ribs still all
cyclized at this point
and what's also important to note is
that
usually these enzymes that
bestow those post insulation
modifications
are encoded in uh genes
that are in the close vicinity of the
gene
of the precursor peptide
and that is um very similar to
other filamentous fungi secondary
metabolites
so here just showing the structure of
three characterized fungal rips
and what these three have in common is
that they're
all cleaved by certain peptidase called
calcium
uh protease and the hallmark of this
cacson protease
is the conserved cut side which is um
two amino acids um either kk
or kr or uh southerly rr
um and the other thing these three
fungal rips have in common is
this ether bond and and that's
extremely uncommon in and fungal uh
natural products but uh
if you remember from earlier that's also
what victorian has
and that would that's what gave us the
idea that
victoria might actually be a rep and by
us
i mean uh my supervisor hang
um from there we did
what heng likes to call a ritual by
synthetic analysis
um which is borrowed from organic
chemistry
so basically you you look at the final
product and try to figure out
um what the precursors or
the building blocks are to to get to
that final product
and in this case we looked at the
structure and
deduced a hypothetical amino acid
sequence
that would be the backbone of victorian
if victorian was a rip and then we used
that sequence which was
gl key glk laf
to uh query the
genome assembly that gain a group had
previously created
and what we found was a single gene on
um a short read only about
1kb long and at the end of that read
there was a gene
that contained two copies of that
sequence
flanked by the familiar kex and carcine
so that was a good sign however
this gene had no stop codon and
also only two core peptide repeats
which is very little very uncommon
and fungal ribs like um just deluxe
internationally ahead
for example has 16 corporate that
repeats so that gave us idiots probably
this gene is incomplete
also because it was at the end of the
read so what we tried
was reassemble the raw reads from that
sequencing
uh try to extend this contact but um
didn't manage didn't lead anywhere so
then what we decided was to
resequence the genome um
which the majority of the work was done
by
megan mcdonald from anu
and what we decided was to nanopore long
weed sequencing
so um as opposed to illumina sequencing
which
what is what gillian's group did
previously long
nanopore has long reads but lower
fidelity as illumina sequence sequencing
and so we use those long reads um
polish them with the illumina reads from
gillian's previous sequencing effort
and that led to the assembly of 22
supercontext
and and this genome assembly then we
query it again with
the sequence of the core peptide and
what we found was actually
not one but three copies of the
precursor peptide gene which is
so far unprecedented in in fungal ribs
and the other thing that was highly
unusual was that um
around those three p precursor peptide
genes
there wasn't a clear gene cluster as
you usually have in fungal rips or even
fungal secondary metabolites as i
mentioned earlier
but only a sort of a diffuse clustering
big distances between genes a lot of
repeat regions and
a lot of transposons so we did
a little bit of a analysis of the genome
um so what you can see here is just
a heat map that maps the three prime and
five prime
endogenic regions
of the entire genome and then we mapped
those candidate genes i'll talk about
that in a second
the genes that we potentially think
might be involved in victorian
um onto this heat map and what you can
see is that
uh the antigenic distances are sort of
above
average compared to the rest of the
genome
um i actually saw that uh sophine camun
gave
a talk uh he recently used on the
youtube playlist
and i think he and his his uh lab came
up
with the concept of of the two-speed
genome
where um
uh basically says that um filamentous
planned pathogens uh have this
sometimes have this genomic architecture
where
um the effect are in genomic regions
that evolve at an
accelerated speed compared to the rest
of the genome which
gives the pathogen the advantage of a
sort of a fast evolution in
the arms race between um pathogen and
host
but at the same time keeps like the
housekeeping and the
the important um genes shielded from
that
uh faster evolution so
that was uh one thing that we thought
might be going on here might be the
reason for this um
sort of unusual architecture um yeah
what i forgot to mention is that
um what the hallmarks of this two-speed
genome of these
regions of accelerated speed are
gene sparsity and a lot of
transposons in those regions and that's
exactly what we observed here
um yeah so just for comparison this is
the ustiloxin cluster um which is one of
the
three um reps that i showed you earlier
as you can see a much more uh
clean cluster uh small intergenic
distances
everything is close together so that's
just comparison to what we found
so that made it a little more difficult
because
um when we elucidate um by synthesis
of of compounds from the
from the genome side we usually rely on
clustering at least to help us to
identify
um potential genes um
that might be involved in
assembling the final product so say if
we look at an
rps then um we know where the mps
gene is but we also look at the
surrounds and then
have sort of the surrounding genes as
candidates
for also being involved and and the
biosynthesis
of that non-ribosome peptide here though
that was a little more difficult because
the the distances were bigger i was
not as clear-cut so one way to
sort of circumvent that is to
look for homologous clusters in other
genomes
in the hope that there's a better
cluster in there also to compare which
genes are conserved between the clusters
and which ones aren't so what we did was
look for homologs of
the precursor peptide which here is
shown in red
and what we found was two
homologues in the genomes of two
distantly related fungi
um apiaspora multani
it the trichomery mclean
and as you can see the surroundings of
those two
look much nicer like much more of a
cluster so that was helpful
and so from that we sort of made a list
of
um canada genes that we suspected
might be involved in victorian
biosynthesis
and um for that we
we basically relied on three things
one sort of the the proximity to the
precursor peptide gene
um although that wasn't as clear cut as
i mentioned um
then the homologous clusters on which
genes are conserved
sort of in the vicinity of the precursor
peptide genes
and then thirdly also what do you
usually find
in fungal rib clusters and at this point
i should mention that
the yellow genes here are df-33 trade
protein genes
and df stands for domain of unknown
function
and these genes are still a bit of a
mystery and
fungal rip biosynthesis and and two
characterized fungal rips they've been
shown to be
involved in cyclization of fungal rips
but um there's often a whole
bunch of them in fungal rib clusters
many more than is needed for cyclization
so
it stands to reason that they're
probably also involved in other
biosynthetic functions that have not
been elucidated yet and
in our case there's quite a bunch um
in the vicinity of these of the
precursor peptide gene copies
so the genes that we decided
on for knockout was firstly obviously
the precursor peptide gene for
confirmation
then we picked one of the df-3328
protein genes
um we also
knocked out the uh and dph
oxidase although that was a dud
and we also knocked out the
copper mean oxidase and brown here
so i'll just go through these mutants
that we created
one by one and talk you through the
results
um oh yeah another thing i should
mention is that
in the collective trichome cluster
there's a cytochrome p450
pretty clearly clustered with the
precursor peptide
and then we found a homolog to that
400 kb from the precursor peptide gene
so um we also include that
in our potential list of potential
victorian biosynthesis genes
okay so um yeah uh
shanghui from uh glen's lab was um
did the heavy lifting and creating all
these knockout strains
um so the first one that we did was
the precursor peptide knockout mutant so
that is delta v a and
looking at the lcms
data that we received from um
that knockout stream was that we
couldn't detect victorian sea anymore
and as i said before victorian sea is
the major consideration that's
by far the most abundant of the
victorian species
and that was somewhat surprising because
for this strain um
only one copy of the precursor peptide
gene genes was missing so we thought
uh we didn't expect to be like that
victorian biosynthesis would be fully
abolished so
um another essay we did was
um similar to what meehan and murphy did
in
47 basically is take the culture
filtrate of those mutants and just
use susceptible old
leaves and just check for disease
symptoms basically building and
this test is known to be uh highly
sensitive
so um what we have is as opposed to
control
the wild type so we should see welding
syndromes and
and all the biological replicates we
have a negative control there's
uh a strain that's uh victor and
negative so those are these
shouldn't be any voting and then for
delta v a
um what we saw was that in some
replicates
we saw the voting syndrome and in others
we didn't so we
interpreted that as um
sort of the victorian production being
so that at the detectable threshold so
it
was
reduced but not fully abolished which
uh sort of made sense to us um
then the next strain um or the next
newton strainer where you look at
um is the delta uh y b strain so
that is one of those d f three three
two eight protein genes and again we
couldn't detect vitamin c
and in the toxicity assays um
we never observed building syndrome uh
symptoms so um the way we interpreted
that is that
probably this gf gene is also involved
in zechalization
of victorian so it creates that
12-minute macro cycle and
what that cycle does is protect the
compound from degradation by
native enzymes so without
the zecharization
the product would quickly degrade within
plan and wouldn't
wouldn't accumulate so that's why we
think we didn't see
any production of any victorian species
in this
as i mentioned before we also knocked
out this
dph oxidase gene
which showed undiminished victorian
production afterwards
so that's not involved in victorian
production what's nice about it is that
that gene is also not in need of the
homologous clusters so that's
a little bit of a validation for our
approach to look at these homologous
clusters
and then lastly the most interesting
mutant was
the knockout of the copper amine oxidase
the k so we saw there is that
again no production of victorian c
we didn't see any toxicity
signs but
um as i mentioned before um victorian is
actually a mixture of
six very similar peptides one of them is
hv toxin m and the difference between
hv toxin m in victorian c is just
um the n terminus so h3 toxin m has
um an unmodified uh amino group at the
end terminus
so the glycine here is unmodified
whereas victorian c
has two hydroxyl group at a position so
you can basically look at
the hv toxin m as being the precursor to
a victorian c
and what we then observed was that um
the delta v k mutant could still produce
hv toxin m
but none of the uh other six
or none of the other five are victorian
species
and all these other five current species
all have that
double hydroxy group at the end so
then we hypothesize that protein the
copper amino oxidase the k
is responsible for um the conversion of
this this amino group at the end
terminus into the double hydroxy group
which is of significance because
it's been shown that this
double hydroxyl group is what gives
victorian
um a big boost in its toxicity
so hv toxin in is uh vastly less
toxic or has less bioactivity compared
to
victorancy or some of the other
victorians here
um yeah so
at the bottom here is sort of our
proposed reaction
done by a reaction done by catalyzed by
vic k and then we hypothesized
that if knocking out vacay
resulted in hv toxin m not being
converted to victorian c
then it will also result in the
precursors of victorian d
b and e which all have um
this double hydroxy group at the end um
not being produced and would result in
the precursor of those
accumulating in the culture filtrate of
the delta vk
mutant so we did
tandem mass spectrometry on that and
that's exactly what we found
we we found do those uh precursors to
those
victorian species um a quick note on
um the tender mass spec data here
um because it might not look that
convincing
to some like this forest of fragment
masses
the reason why we opt not to go for nmr
is because nmr needs
um a huge amount of compound in a pure
form
and that was really difficult to obtain
from the case train because it wasn't
a very strong producer however
it wasn't really necessary either
because we didn't want to do
the novel structural elucidation all we
wanted to do was
compare very similar compounds
so basically um all we need
to to confirm here was that
um if we compare um one of the victorian
species
to its um precursor then
we should see mass shifts only in the
fragments
that contain the n-terminus so that
would be d
and e while the fragments
that don't contain the n-terminus
should have unchanged masses so that was
the case
um and and i guess that's where
tandem ms really shines is just
comparing comparing similar structures
and comparing those
those fragment masses so um
that worked nicely for us
um so then as a final test of um
the case activity sort of as a positive
confirmation
um we did an in vitro essay of the
conversion of
hv toxin m into a victorian c
um what you can see here is basically uh
four different samples so each each line
is a sample and then
each column is
and an extracted acromatogram um
so the left one 798 uh
corresponds to the mass of h3dox and m
the right one 815
to victorian c so the first line is just
the victorian c
standard for comparison second line is
the substrate that we use for for the
assay uh
entry toxin m um as you can see um
the substrate has h2xm doesn't have
victorian c uh yeah what i should
mention is that
we tried to do um we tried to head over
those express
the k in e coli that didn't work so we
used an asset that we
use in this lab sometimes is where we
had a logically
expressed the k in asperger's
netherlands
and instead of purifying the protein we
just
like the cells and use cell free lysate
for our essay so that's what we did here
okay so
um the third line then is
the actual essay so um that's
self-reliant from the k producing
aspergillus mycelium um
plus hv toxins substrate after 14 hours
you can see
that the hbitoxin m has almost
disappeared and
victorian c uh has appeared in nice
quantities
and there's a negative control it's just
empty vector
transformed as which is netherlands um
self-reliant
plus the substrate after 14 hours and
what you can see
is that no victorian c has been produced
however also
h3 talks in m has almost this uh almost
completely disappeared which was
a little bit baffling in the beginning
so we did a follow-up test
and basically just used the empty vector
control self-realize it in a boiled or
unbalanced state and incubated it which
with either
hv toxin m or victorian c and what we
could observe was that
um over time hv toxin m got consumed
whereas victorian c uh remained
relatively stable
so um i guess the disappearance of
etoxin m here then
is explained by selective consumption
um of hv toxin m
um by native aspergillus netherlands
enzymes
yeah so um that was nice nice
confirmation
also worth mentioning that um copper
amino oxidases
are not known in rip uh biosynthesis
so that's a novel one and as i mentioned
earlier it's also really important
for turning the victorian
into its most toxic form
yeah and those are the results from the
paper um
we continue working on the project and
there's
still many many um unsolved
questions for example
what would be really interesting is
finding out what's responsible for the
chlorination
especially since the chlorination takes
place on unactivated carbon centers so
there's a
special kind of um chlorination
also interesting would be what what
enzyme does the contraction of the
um fennel ring um
here to the five-member ring so that
will also be interesting
um we would like to know what all these
df
um genes do um and that would be
really interesting for for fungal grip
by synthesis
in general also from
a genomic architecture standpoint was to
deal with
um the scattering of the vic genes and
where they clustered originally and also
evolutionary what is the origin of the
thick biosynthetic by synthetic genes
because there's no homologues in
its close cousins and cochlear
um yeah that just leads me to
thank a couple people here obviously um
without gillian or
this wouldn't have worked not only like
in our collaboration but also
all the work she did before uh as i
mentioned shanghai did
um a lot of uh work and creating
knockout strengths and all that
um megan did the heavy lifting on all
the sequences and all that from
peter solomon's lab um cmca did the
orbiter
data collection from our lab that's cam
who's also involved
that's hang and also thomas wilbert
was really nice in providing us the
victorian c standard
yeah that's it thank you all for tuning
in and i'll be taking
questions
thank you simon can i be
heard yeah i'm here yeah oh
great that's a blessing yeah
um any questions
for simon
i don't see any in the chat
my first question was going to be
what's what is responsible for the
chlorination
step yeah i mean
if if we knew that that would probably
be another publication um
i mean there's out of the genes we have
identified as as candidates um
there's there's no really obvious uh
candidate here so maybe actually one of
those uf genes
might be involved there um because
there's so many and they got to do
something
at least some of them so that would be
a possibility um but
really there's there's no obvious
smoking gun here yeah
yeah i see
a question in the chat from athena
miss the connection in the
introduction why victorin was
originally thought to be in nrps
what made people start to think about
the possibility of
rip yeah so um
nlps uh just by the unusual amino acids
that are um in the structure of
victorian
so um in an ampere's biosynthesis
there's
potential for modification of or the
incorporation of unusual amino acids
um so so that's why people
first jump to the conclusion that this
might be non-ribosomally
produced um and
the other question was how did we get
the idea that
might be a rip so um
like i said one of the really rare
features
and and from the rips is this uh ether
bone here
so that's really unusual in uh fungal
secondary metabolites
and i remember in 2017 there was a big
review
on fungal cyclic peptides and they
classified all of the
peptides by their chemical makeup
and then they classified basically
cyclic peptides that had an ether bond
and all of them
were from the rips except for victorian
which i said was in nlps
so that's when i started sweating a
little bit it was like um this
baby gives other people the idea too
because at that point we had started our
collaboration
already
yeah i did
um thank you um i see
maria harrison with her hand up
yeah um thanks a really interesting talk
and you mentioned a far away um
p450 that was it was the orange jean in
a cluster somewhere and it was far away
did that one turn out to be part of the
um production of victory
um we haven't said that one yet so um
that would be really interesting to see
because one of the um
more unusual candidates here um
but we have we haven't gotten around to
knocking that one out yet
and i'm also trying to do to
heterologically
reconstruct um the victron pathway which
has turned out to be really difficult as
well
but yeah we're certainly interested in
that and we're working on it
and um it is
sort of uh conspicuous that it is on the
same context as
at least part of the victorian genes
i search for homologs on
in the victorian genome and in other
genomes and it's
actually not it's a rare find so
if it actually just by accident happened
to be
uh next to the
[Music]
college trichome cluster as well as on
the same context as
the victorian genes that will be um yeah
bad luck basically for us yeah
um claire castile has a
question in the chat um are any known
plant
rips also involved in plant
defense
i'm not sure i'm not an expert on plant
rips
i know i can't answer that question i
don't know i don't know fungal rips
yeah um i think it's fair to say
that we know very little about function
of
any of these rip clusters
they're not now that we have
genome sequence we can pick
easily pick out nrps's and
polyketides synthases etc
but it's very difficult unless you
start with a molecule
as was done for victorin
to actually screen
genomes for these molecules
much less test function
and as i understand i think in plants
also you don't have these
um convenient gene clusters so it's even
more difficult there
to do the reverse sort of search
from from the molecule to producing
cluster
yes any other
questions for simon
uh somebody many of us
uh are grateful for you
staying up so late ah no problem
thank you so much yeah thanks for the
invitation and thanks for tuning in
yeah thanks for your terrific work
all right get to bed yes i will
thank you bye-bye thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu